ونكمل من التصعيد في مضيق تايوان حيث
تتصاعد التوترات وبشكل تدريجي ما ينذر
بامكانيه حدوث مواجهه في اي وقت طبعا
فالصين ماضيه في مناورات عسكريه حول جزيره
تايوان ردا على زياره رئيسه تايوان
للولايات المتحده
ولقائها بالمسؤولين الامريكيين فاين
بالتحديد هذه التدريبات الصينيه وما هو
حجم هذه التدريبات بحسب مصدر امنيات
تايواني فان التدريبات الصينيه تقع حول
قناه باشي التي تفصل تايوان عن الفلبين
التدريبات الصينيه تضمنت محاكاه لضربات
دقيقه على اهداف رئيسيه في تايوان ولتطويق
الجزيره
وبالكامل وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه تقول
انها رصدت مقاتلات صينيه من بينها مقاتلات
سو 30 وقذفات h6 الى جانب احدى عشره سفينه
حربيه اخرى في محيط الجزيره من جانبها
قالت رويترز نقلا عن مصادر مطلعه ان
المواجهات باتت وشيكه حيث تتواجد عشره سفن
صينيه ومثلها الحيوانيه على خط المواجهه
بالقرب من الخط الاوسط للجزيره تايبيي
اكدت انها لن تسهم في التصعيد لكنها توعدت
بالرد وبالشكل الملائم على تدريبات بكين
واشنطن حليفه تايوان من جانبها قالت انها
تراقب المناورات الصينيه عن كثب مؤكده
انها تمتلك ما يكفي من موارد وقدرات لضمان
السلامه والاستقرار بالمنطقه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات